werben statt zwang die kanzlerin ruft
die deutschen auf sich impfen zu lassen
eine impfpflicht lehnt sie ab da braut
sich was zusammen deutschland im
dauerregen mit gewitterstürmen und
hagelschlag wir fragen warum ist das so
und proteste in kuba die sozialistische
regierung reagiert mit härte der
us-präsident spricht vom ruf der
freiheit
die nachrichten nicht dass heute mit
christian sievers sehen sie uns 20
minuten für diesen nachrichten dienstag
guten abend hinein christian ist hier
und zuständig für den sportlichen teil
voller freude der guten abend keine
impfpflicht aber eindringlich werben für
das impfen dass es die linie der
bundeskanzlerin
sie war heute im robert-koch-institut
zur gast zu einem zeitpunkt an dem
deutschland weit entferntes davon dass
85 prozent der menschen über zwölf
geimpft sind
das wäre der richtwert den experten für
nötig halten um die pandemie im griff zu
haben
gucken wir uns die sogenannte sieben
tage incidents mal an dass es der wert
der zeigt wie viele sich aus einer
gruppe von 100.000 menschen innerhalb
einer woche neu infiziert haben letzten
dienstag waren es 4,9
mittlerweile sind es 6,5 die zahl ist
auf sehr niedrigem niveau aber sie
steigt und die sorge dass das so
weitergeht auch beim thema impfpflicht
bleibt die bundesregierung aber bei
ihrem nein
patricia wiedemeier berichtet sie kam um
sich für die arbeit der letzten monate
zu bedanken es wurde eine werbeaktion
für chemischen kanzlerin merkel heute
morgen zu besuch beim
robert-koch-institut immer noch ist eine
mehrheit der deutschen nicht doppelt
geimpft die impfquote zugelegt daher ihr
appell an alle die noch unsicher sind
eine impfung schützt nicht nur sie
sondern auch immer jemanden dem sie nahe
stehen der ihnen wichtig ist den sie
lieben eine impfung bewahrt nicht nur
vor schwerer krankheit und schmerz
sondern auch vor dem belasten
belastenden beschränkungen unseres
alltags und je mehr geimpft sind umso
freier werden wir wieder sein um mit
aggressiven varianten des virus klar zu
kommen brauche es eine deutlich höhere
impfquote auch um kinder unter zwölf zu
schützen
für die es nach wie vor keinen impfstoff
gibt es gibt keine ausreden mehr
der impfstoff ist genug da termine sind
leicht zu bekommen es muss uns gelingen
die impfung zu den menschen zu können
und dass wenn wir ein aufsuchen das
impfangebot komplettes wochenende in
sindelfingen
in einem einkaufszentrum der wurden mehr
als 1000 menschen am wochenende geimpft
eine impfpflicht für gesundheitspersonal
oder lehrer wie zum beispiel in
frankreich lehnt merkel jedoch ab ebenso
wie die vorsitzende des ethikrates
wir haben viel bessere ihn fragten bei
den unterschiedlichen berufsgruppen als
beispielsweise in frankreich also beim
gesundheitspersonal oder bei den
lehrerinnen und lehrern haben wir
wirklich super ihn fragen
und deswegen glaube ich brauchen wir das
gar nicht man müsse besser kommunizieren
mehr um vertrauen in die impfung werben
und genau das haben merkel und sparen
heute versucht anders als die kanzlerin
will frankreichs präsident der manuell
mal krank oder mit neuen einschränkungen
in schach halten
seine fernsehansprache gestern macht
offenbar eindruck noch am abend buchten
fast eine million franzosen impftermine
vor allem jüngere menschen
konkret hatte makro eine impfpflicht für
das gesundheitspersonal angekündigt und
arbeitsverbot bei verstößen
außerdem wird für nicht geimpfte etwa
der zugang zu innenräume von restaurants
bars kinos und theatern erschwert die
pandemie in den griff zu bekommen müsse
auch weltweit viel mehr geimpft werden
fordern fachleute immer wieder genau
darum bemüht sich das kovacs programm
hinter dem unter anderem die
weltgesundheitsorganisation steht das
ende des jahres soll das programm ärmere
länder mit 1,3 milliarden impfdosen
beliefern
wie schwierig das ist zeigt sich
beispielhaft in einem der ärmsten länder
der welt der zentralafrikanischen
republik
weil es dort viele probleme gleichzeitig
gibt und nicht genug impfstoff bei den
menschen ankommt wie unser reporter
peter theißen zeugt seit wochen wartet
leons in gambia auf seine erste corona
impfung heute endlich sind in der
stadtbus mb 22.000 astrazeneca
eingetroffen
ich habe schon leute stadt und see namco
wird die krankheit ist realität
bisher tut es nicht weh gerade mal 80
1000 dosen hat die zentralafrikanische
republik bisher aus dem internationalen
kovacs hilfsprogramm bekommen ein paar
tropfen auf den heißen stein
pro gruppe 1 das sind hier die über
50-jährigen denn die durchschnittliche
lebenserwartung beträgt in dem vom
bürgerkrieg erschütterten land gerade
mal 53 jahre der niedrigste wert
weltweit
die regierung warnt auf plakaten vor der
gefahr durch das virus der korona
beauftragte fordert die freigabe der
impf patente das wäre sehr nützlich das
wissen sollte allen ländern und auch der
bevölkerung zentralafrika zugänglich
sein
wichtig wäre zunächst aber das schnell
viel mehr impfstoff ins land kenne
im land gibt gute teams es gab eine
große kinderlähmung kampagne bis vor
zwei jahren also diese teams sind alle
bereiche business nixdorf am krankenhaus
von lausanne biel arbeitet gerade für
ein halbes jahr eine deutsche ärztin mit
sie impft gegen korona gefahr drohe aber
auch durch andere krankheiten
massenweise leute an mangelernährung
das durchschnittsalter der bevölkerung
ist ja auch anders die menschen hier
kämpfen an vielen fronten ums überleben
corona ist für die zentralafrikaner ein
weiteres problem zu einem ganz anderen
thema heute abend zurück nach
deutschland starkregen ergiebiger regen
stundenlanger dauerregen hagelgewitter
hochwassers kaum eine nachrichtensendung
ohne amtliche wetterwarnung in diesem
sommer so geht das seit vielen tagen und
es ist kein ende in sicht im aktuellen
wetterbericht kommt das wort starkregen
wiederholt vor
erst im südwesten dann weiter richtung
norden die folgen zeigt pablo sie dabei
der campingplatz sonneneck in boppard am
rhein
eigentlich sollte hier nach monaten
corona zwangspause die urlaubssaison so
richtig losgehen
doch jetzt herrscht hier land unter die
gäste bleiben aus
wie auch auf diesem campingplatz in der
eifel
wir haben die stromverteiler haben wir
von den plätzen runtergeholt wir haben
alles abgestellt strom abgestellt wasser
abgestellt
wir haben glaube 200 sandsäcke schon mal
gefüllt
und ja das ist im moment alles was wir
tun können und man hat uns gesagt es
könnte bis 200 milliliter bis 200 liter
auf dem quadratmeter von oben runter
kommen mehr als 200 liter regen pro
quadratmeter das ist mehr als das
doppelte dessen was in der region sonst
im ganzen monat juli üblich ist auch die
rheinpromenade von köln steht schon in
teilen unter wasser
der deutsche wetterdienst hat angesichts
der wassermassen für den westen die
höchste und wetter warnstufe
herausgegeben das ist selten
auch der süden und osten ist von
unwetter betroffen selbst in franken
innerhalb kürzester zeit wurde der ort
fast komplett überflutet 70 liter regen
auf den quadratmeter
zuvor hatte das unwetter schon in der
alpenregion gewütet wie zerstörerisch
seine kraft sein kann zeigen diese
bilder aus zürich mit über 100
kilometern pro stunde zog das gewitter
in der vergangenen nacht über die stadt
und entspannung ist nicht in sicht ja im
gegenteil höchste warnstufe haben wir
gerade gehört zdf meteorologin katja
hornuf als bei uns gute nahm katja wo
genau müssen sich denn die menschen
jetzt in deutschland auf das schlimmste
einstellen aktuell ist die größte gefahr
durch gewitter gegeben die sind jetzt im
laufe des nachmittags aus den alpen
nordwärts besonders über bayern gezogen
inzwischen gewittert es aber nicht mehr
nur in bayern sondern auch in thüringen
und im westlichen sachsen heftig das
sind zum teil gewitterwolken an deren
unterkante rotation zu beobachten ist
dann drohen auch tornados hagel
starkregen und sturmböen bringen die
goethe auch mit und im westen gibt es
den dauerregen
ich hatte ja das ist jetzt gefüllt ein
sommer in dem der regen überhaupt nicht
mehr aufhört woran liegt das da steckt
der jet dahinter die drehung der erde
und der temperaturunterschied zwischen
subtropen und arktis treiben ein starkes
westwind band in zehn kilometer höhe an
dieser jet ist sowas wie die leitplanke
für hochs und tiefs da es wärmer wird
das eis der arktis taut schwächelt der
jet und bolt immer häufiger stark aus
thies verharren wie das unwetter tief
über uns
es war wirbelt die hitze über
südosteuropa und die kühle vom atlantik
und diese explosive mischung die macht
an den hitzestress den dauerregen und
die extrem gewitter katja herzlichen
dank für heute und diese unwetter
warnungen gelten weiter zum teil bis
donnerstag früh auf zdf heute.de und in
unserer app finden sie weitere aktuelle
meldungen und hintergründe zu dieser
ganz besonderen wetterlage bei uns jetzt
in der sendung zu einer gruppe von
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürgern bei uns
die immer noch mit vorurteilen zu
kämpfen hat und von manchen hier in
deutschland auch schlicht abgelehnt wird
die sinti und roma wie groß die
diskriminierung ist unter der sie leiden
zeigt jetzt ein bericht von experten den
die bundesregierung in auftrag gegeben
hat zwei kernaussagen die politik muss
sich noch klarer zu sinti und roma
bekennen und der gesamtgesellschaft ist
oft gar nicht bewusst wie sich
diskriminierung für betroffene anfühlt
antonioni berichtet die slow benjamin
hacker ist zehnter geboren und
aufgewachsen in offenburg nach dem
abitur hat der kaufmann gelernt ist
verheiratet und hat zwei kinder
ein ganz normaler bürger aber seit er
für die rechte seiner volksgruppe der
sinti oder roma eintritt wird er offen
diskriminiert wie viel beifall von von
freunden und engagiert mitstreitern aber
auch sehr viel motto oder andere
beleidigungen drohungen von rechter
seite oder von menschen denen das
zuwider ist als ich mich engagiere
wer sich wie er zu seiner abstammung
bekennt riskiert als [ __ ]
gebrandmarkt und benachteiligt zu werden
sagt auch der bericht zum antiziganismus
zur anwendung von sinti und roma eine
zentrale aussage ist dass die bedeutung
der diskriminierung von sinti und roma
historischen auch gegenwärtig immer noch
viel zu wenig ernst genommen wird und es
einen dringenden bedarf gibt das problem
wesentlich ernster zu nehmen als das
bisher der fall ist auch teilen weiß
erlebt jeden tag diskriminierung der
fahrende handwerker ist im wohnwagen
unterwegs willkommen sind sie selten
irgendwo so zb wir waren jetzt hier
angekommen da drüben im haus da wird
wie sagt man da zu musik abgespielt wie
zigarren heraus oder sonst irgendwas
also das gibt mir dann schon zu spüren
die diskriminierung aktiv bekämpfen
fordert die unabhängige kommission ein
meilenstein wäre ein staatsvertrag mit
dem zentralrat der sinti und roma als
zeichen der anerkennung zwischen
kultureller identität und nationaler
identität darf kein unterschied gemacht
werden wir haben eine 600 jährige
deutsche geschichte in erster linie sind
wir deutsche ein anfang ist gemacht im
kampf gegen antiziganismus aber nur wenn
die menschen ihre vorurteile ablegen
kann dieser kampf gewonnen werden das
ist schon das zweite mal innerhalb
weniger monate dass sie im irak ein
krankenhaus gebracht hat wieder traf es
eine corona station und wieder gab es
dutzende tote mindestens 92 menschen
sind bei dem feuer ums leben gekommen
mehr als 50 wurden vermisst er verletzt
möglicherweise war eine
sauerstoffflasche explodiert
verzweifelte angehörige kritisierten das
management im april waren bei einem
brand in einer klinik in bagdad 82
menschen gestorben
auf kuba gibt es die größten
demonstrationen seit mehr als 25 jahren
jetzt wird bekannt es gab mehr als 100
festnahmen einige soziale medien sind
blockiert am wochenende waren tausende
auf der straße unter anderem in der
hauptstadt havanna überwiegend junge
menschen sie kritisieren das
kommunistische regime kuba fehlt es an
vielem lebensmittel medikamente strom
der präsident macht die usa für die
unruhen verantwortlich
newport berichtet
nach der massiven vorgehen der
sicherheitskräfte gegen demonstranten
ist auf den straßen havannas zunächst
wieder ruhe eingekehrt
am sonntag hatten landesweit
zehntausende gegen mangelwirtschaft und
die unterdrückung durch die
kommunistische regierung protestiert sie
skandierten freiheit und nieder mit der
diktatur und ließen sich auch von der
polizei nicht einschüchtern
vor allem junger kubaner fordern
politische reformen sind die
repressionen leid
wir holen uns hier zu tode es gibt
nichts zu essen keine wohnung nichts
staatschef die askanen machte die usa
für die unruhen und die schwere
wirtschaftskrise in seinem land
verantwortlich weil ex-us-präsident
trump die sanktionen gegen kuba immer
weiter verschärft habe
diaz kann er rief zur niederschlagung
der proteste auf ich appelliere an alle
kommunistischen revolutionäre geht auf
die straße beantwortet diese
provokationen auch in den usa wo mehr
als 13 millionen menschen mit
kubanischen wurzeln leben unterstützten
bürger die forderungen nach freiheit
präsident biden erklärte seine regierung
stehe an der seite der kubaner
wir rufen die kubanische regierung auf
die stimme des volkes nicht mit gewalt
zu unterdrücken
die kubanischen behörden haben die
sicherheitsmaßnahmen im ganzen land
verschärft
aber die menschen haben keine angst mehr
ich weiß nicht vielleicht gehen die
proteste weiter
trotz sperrung vieler sozialer medien
könnte es schon am nächsten wochenende
wieder zu unruhen kommen
die regierung will alles tun um das zu
verhindern
in südafrika halten die unruhen nach der
inhaftierung des früheren präsidenten
jacob zuma an
mindestens 45 menschen wurden getötet
tausende plünderten supermärkte und
geschäfte in mehreren städten des landes
rund 750 menschen wurden festgenommen
auslöser war das summer vor sechs tagen
eine haft angetreten hatte er war
verurteilt worden weil er sich in einem
korruptionsverfahren weigerte mit einer
untersuchungskommission
zusammenzuarbeiten
wie kann man die bundeswehrsoldaten nach
ihrem afghanistan einsatz angemessen
würdigen
zunächst waren eine gedenkfeier und ein
appell im berliner bendlerblock geplant
jetzt haben sich
bundesregierung und parlament darauf
geeinigt dass es zusätzlich einen großen
zapfenstreich geben soll
vor dem bundestag am 31 august der große
zapfenstreich ist das höchste
militärische zeremoniell der bundeswehr
deutschland soll jetzt auch im all
verteidigt werden die bundeswehr hat
ihre weltraum kommando heute in
nordrhein-westfalen in dienst gestellt
zunächst 80 soldatinnen und soldaten
sollen von dort aus den schutz und die
überwachung von satelliten übernehmen
zudem soll das kommando weltraumschrott
beobachten und als teil der
militärischen aufklärung aktivitäten
anderer staaten analysieren
verteidigungsministerin annegret kramp
karrenbauer sagte es gehe um defensive
operation und vom weltraum kommando
zurück auf die erde und zum sport und
wir haben zwei themen schwierige
missionen für stefan kunz er kann beim
olympischen fußballturnier in japan nur
auf 18 der möglichen 22 widersetzen
der grund zuviele absagen auch für u
21-europameister ist meine jacobs der
zum as monaco wechselt gibt es keinen
ersatz
stell dir vor es ist olympia und kaum
einer will oder darf dorthin so in etwa
ließe sich etwas zugespitzt die
situation um das team von stefan kunst
darstellen
die olympischen spiele für viele
vereinsmanager er ein unliebsamer termin
ich glaube wir haben da so ein kleines
signal verpasst weil ich glaube nicht
dass bei olympia wenn nicht aus
sportlichen gründen ihren kader platz
frei bleibt bei den anderen sportarten
das hätte uns gut zu gesicht gestanden
im fußball wenn man auch da gezeigt
hätten
diesen respekt zollen da auch stefan
kunst stehen nur vier spieler zur
verfügung mit denen er vor einem monat
überraschend europameister wurde
max kruse von kunst nun sechs jahre nach
dessen letztem einsatz in der a
mannschaft zurück geholt hat wenig
verständnis für die vielen absagen
solange wir elf leute auf den platz
kriegen werden wir alles versuchen um
die goldmedaille hat deutschland schon
realistisch oder zu verwegen erste
erkenntnisse gibt es am 22 juli nach dem
auftaktspiel gegen olympiasieger
brasilien abschlusswoche bei der tour de
france die 16 etappe in den pyrenäen
erneut etwas für ausreise und perfekt
für den österreicher patrick konrad der
bei schwierigen bedingungen den größten
erfolg seiner karriere verbuchte 169
kilometer mitten durch die pyrenäen auf
rauem asphalt mit vielen kurven bei
regnerischem wetter absetzen kann sich
patrick konrad vom deutschen bohrer
hansgrohe team bereits vor dem anstieg
zum col de portet as p die abfahrt
gefährlich vor allem bei nässe
der 29-jährige aber souverän mit 42
sekunden vorsprung wohl der
österreichische meister ungefährdet
seinen ersten internationalen sieg
[Musik]
das gelbe trikot trägt weiterhin der
slowene tadday poker klar dass wir auch
morgen verteidigen auf der königsetappe
lass mich raten morgen auch hier in der
sendung das zeigen hier hat sich
interessieren so und auf einem feld in
der nähe von verona hat zeigt sich
gerade wie groß die freude über den em
titel in italien ist der künstler dario
gambarini hat zu ehren der italienischen
mannschaft mal ein bisschen gepflügt mit
einem traktor als pinsel
der pokal ist 200 meter groß ein zeichen
von stolz und so sagt er
ein symbol der hoffnung auf ein neustart
nach der pandemie und übrigens schönes
wetter da ein bewohner sehe ich gerade
über die riesigen regenmengen bei uns
haben wir ja schon gesprochen gleich
gibt's von katja horneffer noch die
genaue prognose für die nacht und für
morgen
der kollege claus kleber hat das heute
journal um 21.45 von uns hier war es das
für heute danke dass sie dabei waren bis
morgen hinein einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
guten abend hitzestress dauerregen und
extreme gewitter für all das
verantwortlich ist dieses tief das sich
nur wenig von der stelle rührt uns
erwarten gewitter mit hagel mit regen
und sturmböen und auch tornados sind
nicht ausgeschlossen
dieses tiefe wirbel heiße luft aus
osteuropa und auch morgen steigen dort
die temperaturen auf 30 bis 40 grad mit
kühlerer luft vom atlantik da liegen die
temperaturen nämlich im osten
frankreichs nur so bei 19 bis 20 grad
die großen temperaturunterschiede merken
wir auch in der nacht im norden kühlt es
kaum ab bei 20 bis 18 grad im südwesten
sinken die werte auf 13 bis 10 grad und
die gewitter heute abend die ziehen im
laufe der nacht weiter nach norden
erreichen bis zum frühen morgen auch
hannover bremen und hamburg dazu gibt es
kräftige dauerregen hier im westen und
das wird uns auch morgen über tag noch
weiter beschäftigen
es gibt weitere kräftige gewitter es ist
weiterhin mit hagel platzregen und
sturmböen zu rechnen und die
temperaturen bleiben sehr
unterschiedlich im norden steigen sie
auf sommerliche 25 bis 30 grad im süden
sind es kaum 18 bis 21 grad und mit
gewittern haben wir es dann auch noch am
donnerstag und am freitag zu tun
am donnerstag vor allen dingen im westen
am freitag im süden und erst zum samstag
beruhigt sich die lage guten abend